back when I first started going on dates
I would get extremely nervous so I
created a ritual in order to calm my
nerves down I would meditate and try to
be as present as possible during the
entire 30 to 45 minute train or bus ride
to the date spot and when I finally got
to my stop I would go out of my way to
have three short but fun interactions
with some strangers around me this
helped me out a lot because I knew that
talking to strangers made me less
nervous and also since these
interactions were almost always positive
I would be in a good mood before the
date even started then after the ritual
is over I made sure that I was as fun
and present as possible during the date
itself and after doing this just three
times it became a ritual that I would do
before every first date I started
feeling less and less nervous each time
because I knew this ritual of mine would
trick me into being more fun and present